موضوع يخص الفن والفنانات خلال لقائهما في
احد البرامج اثارت الفنانه شيرين عبد
الوهاب الجدل مره اخرى هذه المره بعد ان
تحدثت عن صفه لا تحبها في اليسا وقالت
انها تغني وكانها مسكه على الناس ردت
اليسا في تغريده ساخره نشرت فيها صورتين
صوره لها وهي تغني على المسرح وصوره اخرى
لفتاه تحمل شيك علقت كيف يراني الناس وانا
على المسرح وما تراه شيرين لكنها اكدت
انها لا تحمل مشاعر سلبيه رغم ذلك
تصريح شيرين كالعاده قبل بهجوم من محبي
اليسا وعدد من المغربين بينما دافع اخرون
عن شيرين معتبرين انها
لا تقصد الاساءه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات